[Musique] il y a un
avant-goût
étranger
pour
toi,
bien, pouvons-nous descendre au-dessus de ces
arbres, ici les arbres sont devant
nous, bas, bas, bas le long de la
rivière ouais, je d'accord,
c'est bon, ouais, c'est bien, ils suivent
la vallée ou oui, s'il te plaît, suis-nous  la
vallée
ouais
oh il y a des rapides oh
ok tu es parti
p
oh il y a un
où est le sur le côté droit
ok
tellement de paysages différents par ici
cette
aor
est
ok ni rapide La rue de la réf court
ok nous
regardons
stra si tu veux, peux-tu le faire  quelque chose
avec ça ou ouais peut-être juste quand nous arrivons
à tourner à gauche, continue, euh, continue à
le suivre maintenant, d'accord et puis quand nous
obtenons un virage à gauche, va tout droit, ah, frappe par-dessus
la colline, ok, pas maintenant
[Musique]
reviens tout droit maintenant, ne le fais pas  ne va pas
à gauche
ok ok ok allons voler en
ligne droite maintenant arrête arrête ça
ouais
F plus lent
ok
ok arrête
je
hein [ __ ] gauche
[Musique]
[ __ ]
BL BL
BL
allez
[Musique]
c'était sympa
ok ok ouais ouais on a fini ok
devrais-je
aller
dans cette direction, j'ai eu un peu de pluie sur
le Lan, est-ce que ça va pour
toi, n'est-ce pas, je peux voir
[Musique]
quelque chose que tu veux refaire ouais peut-être que je
nettoie
le
L de ce rocher et puis quand nous nous levons, nous
pouvons  laisse-moi me concentrer
d'abord, est-ce que ça va ouais hé
ok A
P
[Musique]
pour refléter le St c'est
ouais ok eh bien on passe juste en revue le continue
ouais ok ok
ouais
arrête
non non
non
ok
penses-tu que le plan comme celui-ci serait
utile le genre de moitié d'hélicoptère à moitié
ouais le making off ouais juste en quelque sorte euh ouais
ok petite chose oh
c'est
beau ouais
le petit
bébé [Musique] a de grands
pieds quoi de
neuf
on ne va pas trop bouger
ok euh
vas-y en un  ouais, il n'y en avait
qu'un seul et
mets ça va être bien peut-être qu'il
cherche
son
essai, essaie le 1 D oh c'est tellement
beau
bonjour mets zéro DB et euh et et
arrête un peu
plus
avec
un ouais ouais prends-y, reviens euh  un Un
D ok
peut-être aller bas autour de la colline pour qu'on soit
hors de vue de l'animal donc il n'arrête pas de
courir
ok il devrait arrêter de courir on
contourne la colline on devrait le voir tu vois euh pas
encore pas encore c'est juste  par-dessus
la
crête
ok ouais tu l'as ouais juste en
blanc oh il va sur l'autre je vois en
haut juste le son
ouais je veux dire ça suffit tu ne penses pas
ouais j'essaie juste de prendre une photo et
puis  on
part qu'est-ce qu'on fait
ok
s'arrêter
c'est
pour
ok et
tirer
tourner à
gauche ici c'est
beau quelque part ouais au milieu
d'accord à
gauche le sable à gauche
oui je pense que c'est
mieux
de vérifier d'abord la zone pour B
[Musique]
je
pense
[Musique]
maintenant on change St avant d'arrêter on
arrête
[Rires]
[Musique] [
Musique]
ok, vois un peu de solarisation au milieu
de l'eau là le violet au
milieu tu veux le
[Musique]
milieu  où veux-tu qu'est-ce que tu
dis non non non je ne parle pas de
l'image de la caméra ok tu as du
Rising ouais et euh je
te montrerai ouais je te montrerai quand on arrêtera
[Musique]
ok
parfait
stop  maintenant